it's fair to say that this year's
biggest movies are probably going to
make some serious bank at the box office
but these aren't them from iffy
adaptations to unnecessary sequels these
are the movies that are
bound to bomb in 2021
the aptly named chaos walking has been
in development since 2011.
long before its stars daisy ridley and
tom holland were even a thing in
hollywood
even after the project finally made it
out of development hell poor test
screenings forced multiple rewrites and
reshoots the movie is based on patrick
ness's young adult novel the knife of
never letting go which is the first book
in his chaos walking trilogy
it follows a mysterious alien girl named
viola who crash lands on a world without
any women and where men are affected by
the noise an affliction that causes them
to constantly hear each other's thoughts
there she meets todd who must unlock his
own inner powers to protect viola from
the evil mayor
feel like you've seen all this before no
one could blame you
and the film's troubled 10-year
production history doesn't inspire much
confidence either
sure ridley and holland had strong lead
roles in the two most popular franchises
ever
but now it's looking increasingly like
they've walked into chaos
don't expect moviegoers to follow them
let's face it hollywood is addicted to
rehashing tired intellectual properties
case in point the upcoming masters of
the universe reboot
sure it was a hugely popular cartoon tv
show and
action figure series but that was back
in 1985.
just two years later the power of
greyskull had already worn off as the
original live-action masters of the
universe movie tanked earning just 17
million dollars worldwide
and honestly it's hard to believe
anything has changed in the past three
decades
it's possible that sony sees this as
another potential transformers franchise
but there's a real chance that the
nostalgia train for the he-man brand ran
out of steam
a long time ago it's also been an
eternia since
anyone has heard anything official about
the movie with the last real
announcement being that disney channel
heartthrob
noah centeno had signed up to play
he-man himself
on top of that a shift in release date
for the uncharted movie recently pushed
masters of the universe off the calendar
so it's not even certain whether this
one will be coming in 2021 at all
if and when it does hit theaters though
well just don't get your hopes up for a
sequel
shocking absolutely nobody 2017's the
boss baby was a critical disaster
garnering a 53
critic score and a 51 audience score on
rotten tomatoes
still the concept was clearly enough to
catch the public's attention
earning it 175 million dollars
domestically and 527 million dollars
worldwide
those are shockingly good numbers and
they were highly profitable too
since the movie was made on a 125
million dollar budget
unfortunately this made a sequel pretty
much inevitable
and sure enough in september 2021 the
boss baby family business
is due to hit theaters but things
probably won't turn out so well this
time
a negative audience score on sites like
rotten tomatoes suggest that
although people flocked to see the first
movie nobody actually liked it
it's also been four years since the
first movie was released meaning
what little goodwill it earned at the
time has long since worn off
throw in a tired premise and 90 minutes
of fairly dumb jokes and you've got a
recipe for a box office catastrophe
it's likely that sony are hoping their
upcoming marvel flick morbius will
replicate the success of 2018's venom
another spider-man spin-off set in the
same universe but there's really no
reason to believe this will happen
for one back in the day venom's
popularity rivaled that of spider-man
himself
conversely most casual spider-man fans
probably don't really remember morbius's
connection to the spidey series
more importantly though venom starred
tom hardy whose fanboy
bonafides were well established
following the dark knight rises and
mad max fury road thanks to hardy's
natural charisma and star power
audiences learned to love venom despite
its negative reviews and the movie raked
in a stunning 853 million dollars
worldwide
what does morbius have jared leto who's
probably best known in the comic book
world for playing the worst
joker ever
the only thing that could really save
morbius is a whole heap of stellar
reviews and we wouldn't count on that
happening either
make no mistake there aren't many butts
in seats movie stars left but mark
wahlberg probably makes the list
wahlberg's movies have earned more than
3 billion domestically and 6.4 billion
dollars worldwide
and although those numbers have been
juiced a little by the transformers
franchise there's no doubt wahlberg had
at least something to do with them
things are a little trickier these days
though
wahlberg's last hit in an action role
was spencer confidential but that
debuted on netflix not in theaters
meanwhile one of his recent bombs mile
22 tanked in theaters but landed in
netflix top 10 in november so where does
that leave his latest picture
infinite well if it keeps its current
theatrical release date on memorial day
weekend
opposite disney's cruella spin-off it's
pretty much toast
while it could have been a decent action
oriented counter programmer for disney's
movie a little flick called fast and
furious 9 is due for release a weekend
earlier
and that movie is guaranteed to win out
over infinite any day
for now it seems like the only thing
that can save wahlberg's latest
is a swift move to netflix or a shift in
release date
everyone loves a little sly stallone but
there's no denying that since the 1990s
his box office record has been
pretty spotty outside the usual
franchise fair that is
still you can't fault a guy for trying
clearly hoping to keep making action
movies well into his sunset year
stallone's next feature currently slated
for june 4th
is the superhero thriller samaritan the
movie follows a young boy who discovers
that a superhero who went missing 20
years ago
is still very much alive and well it's
an intriguing premise and one that might
have given the movie a chance had it
kept to its pre-pandemic fall 2020
release date alas the summer movie
season is likely to swallow samaritan
whole
there's also an issue with tone here the
movie is supposed to be a darker edgier
take on the world of superheroes and
while that may prove
popular with critics it's unlikely to
draw much of a crowd
stallone's older fan base is unlikely to
show up for yet another dark
gritty superhero movie while younger
moviegoers aren't going to be too keen
on watching an
old dude kick ass especially if he's not
having fun while he's doing it so
although samaritan may turn out to be
pretty great
well let's just say you probably
shouldn't get your hopes up for a sequel
the tomorrow war didn't stand much of a
chance at the box office when it was due
to be released on christmas day 2020 and
things aren't looking much better now
that it's been delayed to an even
tougher summer release of july 23
2021. what's worse deadline reported in
january 2021 that the film was being
shot to streamers so there's a chance
the tomorrow war might not even see a
theatrical release at all
while the film stars chris pratt who is
about as reliable a movie star as you
can get it's also a concept heavy sci-fi
film which is always a risky bet
the setup sounds promising at least
humans are losing a war in the future
so they go back in time to recruit a
number of legendary soldiers from the
past
it sounds pretty similar to tom cruise's
edge of tomorrow which scratched and
clawed its way to 100 million dollars
domestically after a meek
28 million dollar opening but even with
367 million dollars worldwide that movie
barely made back its mammoth 178 million
dollar budget the tomorrow war will be
facing a similar battle should it even
make it to a market that's changed
dramatically since 2014.
had the tomorrow war open during the
holidays of a non-pandemic year the high
daily grosses
may have carried it to profitability in
the sink or swim
opening weekend obsessed summer though
even chris pratt will have problems
pulling that off
releasing a prequel to a popular movie
franchise is always a risky proposition
but to a mediocre one that's just asking
for trouble
enter snake eyes gi joe origins
currently scheduled for release in
october 2021
another popular toy line and cartoon
that made the leap to the big screen
the gi joe franchise has proven to be a
mixed bag at the box office
gi joe the rise of cobra opened strong
with 54 million dollars in 2009 but it
failed to keep up interest
and with a 175 million dollar price tag
the movie turned out to be a bomb
paramount spent 140 million dollars on
his 2013 sequel gi joe retaliation which
managed to bring in a tidy profit thanks
to a decent performance at the worldwide
box office
however nearly a decade has passed since
that movie which despite being totally
forgettable benefited by plastering
dwayne johnson's mug
all over its marketing materials a
rockless prequel eight years later
not a chance ben affleck's career has
been
kinda spotty lately but following his
big time comeback with argo and gone
girl
it seemed like he'd finally won back a
little street cred
and then of course he decided to play
batman sure
affleck did a good enough job in the
role and the dc eu movies are
technically his biggest grossers but
they were also pretty underwhelming
and seemed to have killed off the
credibility he had managed to claw back
while the accountant did well back in
2016
his follow-up movies live by night and
the way back
bombed hard earning less than 40 million
dollars worldwide combined
and now there's deep water scheduled for
a november 2021 release the movie seems
to be echoing gone girl by having
affleck play the sleazy husband in a
movie based on a popular novel with
knives out breakout star anna de armas
co-starring the stars are aligned for
deep water to do well with critics
as for the box office though everything
will come down to whether affleck
himself can shed
all that baggage it might be hard to
believe but before deadpool's
record-breaking run
in 2016 ryan reynolds was box office
poison
his career mostly involved playing
supporting roles to bigger names
featuring in a string of so-so genre
flicks and starring in a handful of
genuine bombs
bad deadpool his latest free guy seems
poised to fall into the latter category
which will no doubt leave box office
analysts wondering if reynolds can carry
a movie without help from the merc with
a mouth
disney may be wondering the same thing
too as they've removed free guy from
their release calendar
given the movie was originally set for a
july 2020 release but was pushed back to
december it might have been fair to
assume this was just another pandemic
related pushback
except that disney announced a newer
release date
free guy will be freed on may 21
2021 it's not exactly clear if it's
doing the duel
movie theater streaming thingy yet so
keep your ears peeled
if it heads to disney plus that pretty
much tells you what disney thinks of the
film
good thing reynolds has deadpool 3 to
look forward to the kingsman franchise
has proven to be a surprisingly
profitable blockbuster series despite
not being based on a mainstream property
kingsman the secret service earned 128
million dollars domestically and 404
million dollars worldwide on a 94
million dollar budget
while kingsman the golden circle earned
a little less domestically but
a little more overseas on a slightly
higher budget obviously a downward trend
is never a good sign though hollywood
has seen worse drop-offs over the years
the bigger cause for concern is that the
next film
the king's man isn't a sequel reuniting
the original cast but a period prequel
set decades before the previous films
the premise sounds great following one
man and his protege
banding together to stop history's worst
tyrants from plotting a war to wipe out
millions
rafe finds is always a welcome addition
to a movie too
unlike most of his blockbusters however
fines is playing the co-lead here and it
remains to be seen whether he can keep a
big movie afloat all by himself
the king's man has also been delayed
multiple times and while most of those
pushbacks were kovit related the movie
had actually been delayed before the
pandemic struck
which is never a good sign it appears as
though the king's man has a march 2021
theater release date but that may pivot
to a streaming site
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]